Rob here with a gamespot news update
Rockstar Games has announced the next
update for grand theft auto 5 s
multiplayer mode the new update is
titled lowriders and introduces new
lowrider cars and customization options
the update will be available on October
20th for xbox one pc and playstation 4
as of now this is the first update that
isn't coming to last gen the focus of
the lowriders update is a new custom
shop called Benny's original motor works
at the Downtown strawberry shop players
can buy a huge range of lowrider
customization options some of these
include new engine covers and air
filters as well as interior options such
as velour leather or your own custom
colors and designs as you'd expect you
can throw some hydraulics on your car or
beef up your sound system with new
speakers and subwoofers far out just
like the previous update this one will
also add new missions weapons clothing
and hairstyles players will be able to
purchase a fourth piece of property to
make room for all their new cars as
announced previously rockstars focusing
its efforts on new generation consoles
and PC for future GTA online updates
remains to be seen if the xbox 360 and
playstation 3 versions of GT online will
receive any further significant content
updates hmm now that is what I call a
pimped-out update for all your gaming
news you go to gamespot com take care
now